Does that not freak you out? Have you ever done that before?
That you can click a button and accidentally cost yourself like $500?
Not even $500. Dude, I read an article on this that was like,
I accidentally charged myself 14 grand. And I'm like, oh no, this is terrifying.
Oh my God.
But the response from the Google SME or whatever was like, dude, I'm so sorry this happened to you.
It was very emotionally mature response too. He was like, I can't imagine what it must be like
to see that number or whatever. But for you to do this, you had to be pretty dumb.
Hey everyone. We've all heard of Project Discovery, right? The authors of Nuclei,
HTTPX, and countless other essential security tools. What you may not have heard of, however,
is their conference, Hardly Strictly Security Conference. This conference is happening April
25th from 8am onward virtually. And it's featuring the topic of everything open source security tooling.
They'll have speakers from top companies like Vercel, Datadog, Hashcorp, and Fastly. And it's
oriented towards anybody who cares about open source security tooling, whether you're a bug hunter,
a red teamer, security leader, whoever. There should be great content for you at this conference.
So if you're interested, head over to nux.gg slash hss24 slash hss24, right? Hardly Strictly Security,
and then 2024 to sign up and register and get in on that conference goodness. All right, with that,
back to the show. Dude, I'm so freaking cold right now.
Like...
Hey, you gotta turn your heat up.
No, it's not that, man. It's the cold showers. Do you do the cold showers?
No, I don't do that. I know a bunch of you do that, and I think you're crazy for it.
Dude, like, I don't normally do it very often, but like, I was, I've, like, I stopped lifting for a
couple weeks, and then I'm getting back into it, and I've been pretty sore. So I was like, all right,
you know, let me see if I can do, like, a cold shower. And now I'm just, like, like, core cold.
You know, like, I'm not cold. Like, I've got, like, plenty of clothes on and, like,
got even the heaters on the feet right now. But, like, something deep in my core is just freezing.
It's freezing. Interesting.
Where are you at, man? You're in a hotel today, yeah?
Yeah, I'm up in, I'm in upstate New York. I'm in Buffalo for the eclipse.
Oh, really? Oh, you went up there to see the eclipse, huh?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I've got some friends up here. So I thought it would be a fun little trip. And,
uh, yeah, yeah, it's, it's exciting. It's a little cloudy right now, but I'm hoping that it clears up.
Hopefully so. That would suck if you went there for that. It's just straight clouds for the whole eclipse.
I know. I saw this crazy graph of, like, Airbnb bookings right on that little band. And it's like,
everything is booked in that entire band.
It's so interesting. Yeah. I mean, the hotels were, like, ridiculously expensive.
Really?
I've stayed here in this area before, and it's, like, usually very, you know, normal hotel prices.
And then it was, like, two or three times minimum as much per night.
Ouch, dude. That sucks, man. That is not a normal thing to pay. Rip.
Yeah, it's, it's a, it's a little bit ridiculous, but I was able to find, you know, a pretty good deal.
So all things considered.
You got, like, the goggles or whatever, the glasses that you need.
I do have the special glasses, you know, I've got, um, you know, these special, special glasses,
so you can look at the sun and stuff. And they're basically like paper welding goggles, you know?
I have a vested interest in you being able to see. So, uh, please, please protect your eyes.
I would, yeah, I'm not going to stare directly at the sun. Don't stare directly at the sun.
Great. Well, what if you stare directly at the moon?
Well, okay, well, uh.
Gosh, on that one. Didn't see that one coming, did you?
Oh my gosh, dude. Okay.
Don't stare, well, maybe you can stare directly at the moon. I don't know.
All right. All right. Well, we'll leave that up to the experts in, you know, astrology,
and we'll get back to our, our lane, which is bug bounty. Where do we want to start out today?
Joel, we got a, we got a decent amount of things on the list today.
Yeah. So there was this, there was this really cool, um, event that I saw. Um,
Yes, We Hack, uh, is running.
Dude, I saw that.
It's over now. I think they ran a live hacking event, um, with Louis Vuitton, which is super cool.
Um, where was this event?
You know, I imagine it was, I believe it was Paris. Um, yes, it was in Paris. And I saw,
you know, I talked to a couple of people that went to the event and saw the pictures online and it looks
pretty freaking well done, you know?
Yeah. It's pretty exciting. I don't know if Yes We Hack has run an event before. Have they run live
hacking events? Or is this their first one?
I think they have done a couple, but I think this is the one that like, for me, this is the one that put
them on the map with regards to like live hacking events. Cause it's like, there've been some small
ones here, there, but Louis Vuitton is a pretty cool target and you know, it's in Paris and the,
the pictures are really good. The swag looked really good. It looked like your awesome time.
Yeah. I mean, it looks really, really sick. So I'm hoping to see more, um, more events from the team,
but it's cool to see such a large, like non-traditional brand doing an event like that.
You know, I'm sure, uh, that other fashion brands and stuff are going to see that and maybe hopefully
get interested in doing security events would be super cool. I know there's so many, um, luxury brand
lovers in the bug bounty hacker scene. The swag for that, for that like event, just,
ah, imagine having like a custom Louis Vuitton, like freaking jacket that they've got there. I don't,
I don't even know. So I haven't even gotten confirmation. I imagine that this is the case,
but I haven't gotten confirmation that those are actually Louis Vuitton jackets.
I don't know, but I don't know. The concept is still pretty cool. I think if it, if it was actually
Louis Vuitton jacket, I would absolutely fly out just for that. You know, sure. For sure. Like,
yeah, I mean, super cool, right? Like once, like one time, super epic swag like that is,
that's super cool. It's such an enticing, uh, enticing. Yeah. So I'm not normally the one to do
stuff like that too. I normally look at this like pretty from like a business perspective, like, okay,
you know, I'm going to have to spend whatever, however much on flying Mariah out and like, you
know, going to go out to the event, that sort of thing is, you know, the opportunity cost of hacking
on other programs when the boundaries aren't quite as high, that sort of thing. But like, I feel like
there's a special niche of swag that's like pretty different, which something that holds mainstream
sway like Louis Vuitton. Right. But I feel like, like, if it was like, all right, we'll give you
like a, I feel like I might do it for like a custom laptop or like, you know, something like that,
but also Louis Vuitton jacket, that would be, that'd be really rad. So I, I, yeah, yeah, exactly.
I didn't really put myself in the category of, of hackers that would go to a live hacking event
just for the swag, not, not considering the bounties and that sort of thing. Like, like,
I probably wouldn't spend a bunch of time on the program if their bounties weren't great, but
I would definitely go and hack for at least a couple of days for that.
Yeah, for sure. I mean, absolutely. You know, hey, if Louis Vuitton wants to send,
uh, send us invites next time. Yeah. Well, I need to go make a yes, we hack account. Cause I don't
even have a yes, we hack account. So yeah, that's true. I don't think I have any there. That's
probably not really helping my chances. Yeah. Yeah. I think we gotta, you know,
do something here to get, to get on the board, but, um, yeah, I was looking at the results. I,
I dropped that tweet in the, in the doc, Joel, but the results, um, for that live hacking event
are up and man, dude, team Spain, they are just crushing it with almost all of the, um,
all of the awards at this event went to team Spain.
Yeah. It looks like they, they worked together, the three of them, cause they all have the same
number of reports. Uh, but yeah, they, they really crushed it in our boy Nagly, of course,
you know, right, right. Not, not far behind them. It's interesting that they won for a second,
third. Um, cause like their points are different, even though they all have,
Oh, check that out. Yeah. Just buy a couple.
Number of reports and stuff. I'm not really sure. Maybe it's just like the severity or I'm not really
sure how the reporting structure works over there, but, um, I would have expected that they would
have been like tied for first. So I think technically Nagly actually got second, uh,
if you're ignoring the points, but yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I, I, I don't know. What do you think about
this? What do you think about like a points-based leaderboard? Because I think that was something
that hacker one did away with really quickly early on in the live hacking event game as they were,
you know, kind of figuring that whole thing out. And I think pretty much every other, you know,
bug bounty platform makes that, in my opinion, mistake of doing it based off of points in the
beginning, um, rather than doing it based off of money. Uh, but then we've seen other, the other,
we've seen bug crowd and integrity both come around on that and sort it by money now. Um, so I'm,
I'm kind of curious as to why yes, we hack isn't doing that.
Yeah. I don't know. Um, I'm not sure why they did it, but it's, I mean, it's an interesting approach.
I think hacker one didn't like the gamification aspect of it where, um, a lot of people were just
like finding ways to gamify that to get on like the top of the leaderboard where, you know,
money like bounty amount is usually a direct correlation with impact. So higher bounties,
higher impact, you know, it's like a pretty good way of sort of like measuring and like having like
a scoring mechanism. Uh, but even on the hacker one leaderboard, you see that there's other ways of
sorting it too. Like they have sorting by like number of reports and number of results and like
that kind of stuff too. So it's not all exclusively just money, but I think that money is a pretty good
way of measuring it. Um, maybe the points are there, they're same, uh, sort of thing.
Yeah. Yeah. Maybe. So I, it definitely depends. Uh, you know, I, I mostly just pay attention to the
bounty amount ones, but then there's also that aspect of like, okay, well, when you've got a
tallying bounty amount, you know, total and you have sorting by bounties and you know, there are those
people that are like, not we that write the scripts and are be like, all right, Justin just got a, you know,
15 K bounty. All right. Note that down in my little notebook. Like, like, I don't know why, you know,
he does this, but he is like freaking bounty, uh, uh, you know, intelligence agency. Cause you can be
like, all right, Natalie, how much did, you know, Justin make at the PayPal event in 2023? And he'll
give you like the number within a 10% plus or minus somehow every time I was like, how do you know that?
Crazy. Like he, he really is like tracking it somewhere somehow. Cause it's, um, he definitely
like has a lot of data on that stuff. Like I remember one time we were in our discord and we were
chatting, we were like, he was like, oh, I know how much everybody's made, you know, like with their
total bounty amounts. I was like, what's mine? And he's like 10 K off. I was like, wow.
Oh wow. Okay. Geez, Natalie, man. He's, he's definitely got some, some data and you know, that's,
that's one of his things, you know, is data. So, uh, it's on brand, but creepy nonetheless,
I must say. Yeah. A little bit, a little bit, the Nagly intelligence network, you know,
but yeah, I did. Um, uh, so shout out to team Spain. They did awesome. Shout out to Piku Haku,
uh, or HakuPiku, depending on where you are in the, uh, you know, if you're on discord or on, um,
on Twitter, uh, they got best dressed bug, biggest impact. That's pretty awesome.
Um, and yeah, it looked like an awesome event for sure. Um, very, very cool.
Yeah. What's, so what is this? What is this little, this little note underneath?
Oh, okay.
You have some insider, you have some insider information.
I do have some insider information. So I, I will, you know, normally if it's
Noggly, I'll throw Noggly under the bus. This one was not Noggly, but I did talk to
a couple of other people, um, from that event. And one con that I can say about that event is, um,
the top earners were not actually earning very much. The bounties were not awesome for that event. Um,
so I can say roughly, assuming the, the data is accurate and I probably should double check with
Noggly because he's got good data on all this stuff too, but it seems like quite a bit off. Like
it could be somewhere between one fifth to one tenth of what a, a top earner at a, any given live
hacking event is making or any given hacker one live hacking event is making. So that's a little,
Do you know why that was, there was a bounty table?
Bounty table. I mean, I think it's, I mean, it's gotta be a combination of bounty table and scope,
but I know that there were some exclusive crits, um, that were, that were paid out, you know,
one person crits or whatever. But I believe that the, the bounty table for that event was not very
high. And that's why, you know, it's a little bit, a little bit discrepancy between hacker ones,
live hacking events and in something like this.
Mm-hmm. Super interesting.
Yeah.
So that, but, but I mean, they're making it, like we said, they're making up for it with the,
with the crazy, you know, target and the crazy swag. Cause like, how sick would it be to be like,
I just was spent the weekend hacking Louis Vuitton. It was pretty bad.
I know. Right. It's super cool. It's super cool. I, I love, I mean, there, that's always like one
of the really cool aspects of the LHU's is like the name aspect and like getting to hack these big
companies and stuff. Yeah. All right, dude, let's, uh, let's jump over to the browser market share
stuff because this is a really interesting topic that we were having a discussion around in the
discord recently. And so I went and like double clicked on it a little bit and figured out some
details and I highlighted the, the interesting ones there in the doc, Joel. But so I feel like a lot
of people throw around this, this number of like, um, Safari having a decent amount of market share,
um, in the browser space, because if you look it up, it says like 18 point.
Yeah. It's like the second most used browser, right?
Yeah. Second most used browser, 18.5%. Um, and they still have not adopted same site lacks default. So,
uh, that this really affects, you know, C-SERVs. Um, but if you look into it a little bit more
and you look at the breakdown for this, you know, there's, there's desktop users and there's mobile
users, and maybe I'm just thinking about this wrong, but, um, desktop users only have, uh, Safari only has
8% of desktop users and they all, and they have 24% of mobile users, right? Which, which makes sense
because iOS is kind of a bigger platform on mobile for sure. Um, but I feel like a lot of the apps
that we hack are like, not something that you casually log into on your phone. Maybe I'm off with
that. Cause I, I know that the, the statistics are pretty high on like 70% of web traffic is like
mobile or something like that. But I feel like there, you know, when we're reporting stuff to like
this business analytics platform or something like that, I feel like people aren't going to be
logging in on their phone and being like, all right, let me run this report and you know, that sort of
thing. So I feel like knowing what kind of target demographic your website that you're hacking has,
and then being able to give them browser specific exploits and numbers on that could be a helpful
thing. What do you, what do you think about that? Yeah, that's a, that's a good call out. I mean,
I think it is good to sort of break it down into the, like the desktop and the mobile stuff,
because I, that the total stats is it always catches people off guard when you tell them,
oh, you know, like, uh, why don't you tell me like in order, what are the top three browsers?
And most people are going to say, oh, like Chrome, Firefox, um, you know, Safari or edge.
And you're like, nope, Chrome, Safari, edge. And you're like, what? And you know, yeah,
I mean, Safari as a whole almost has 20% of the market, but the reality is that it's mostly mobile
people, um, using iPhones because there's so many iPhones and they don't use an alternative browser.
They just use Safari, um, that they have that large share. Whereas Android, you know,
the default browser is Chrome and the browser that most people use on Android is Chrome,
which is why they have such a high, um, mobile share. Plus, I mean, I use iOS, but I use Chrome on
my phone. Oh, really?
Yeah. That's my browser. Yeah. Yeah. I think a lot of people do. Um,
so it is really interesting. And I think that's a good, like, that's a good idea. Like you should
always kind of be framing your write-ups and your POCs and your bugs and stuff to try and show the
most impact for whatever company you're hacking on. So I think also targeting sort of like, you know,
more people are like, if this is a mobile specific website, then more people are going to be likely to
be using Safari than they want on desktop. And if there's a Safari specific vulnerability, like that,
you can take advantage of same site lacks, uh, no default same site, um, you know, setting then.
Yeah. Yeah. No, I think that makes a lot of sense. And 25%, you know, that's a pretty decent chunk of
mobile traffic. So if you are focusing on a site, like you said, that has mobile presence, then
that's very significant. Um, and not something that I was, I was super well acquainted with, uh, before.
Um, but one thing that I wanted to shout out as well from looking at these statistics was like
Firefox, if you look at the total market share has only a 2.8%, uh, you know, presence and, and then
they're it's 0.5% in mobile, right? So nobody is using Firefox on.
I don't know anybody who uses Firefox mobile browser. And I will say like, I think a lot of more people
used Firefox back in the day. Um, it was a lot more popular of a browser, but then Chrome
like rocketed past it after a while, after, after it sort of like gained popularity and gain a lot of
features and stuff. And then Firefox searched a little bit when they did the, the quantum or whatever,
like the, the rewrote their Firefox, like rewrote their engine to be super fast and optimized.
Um, and that like gave it a performance edge on Chrome. And I think that surged their
popularity, but now there's like so many browsers, like you see opera, right? Like
opera is now like, I would say like a marketing heavy browser where they're like on social media
a lot. They sponsor lots of like YouTube channels and stuff.
2.5%
Yeah. They have almost the same market share as
I would have never thought that that was, that was why this is crazy to me. It was like
opera has the same presence and more presence on mobile than Firefox does. But, um, Firefox still
has 6% of desktop users, which I thought was a little bit higher than expected. Um, so there is,
there is, you know, it's still a little bit hard to sell that because, um, you know, Firefox isn't
doing same set lacks either. Despite if you Google it, it says they are, but they rolled it back. Apparently
I found out recently. Um, uh, and it's so 6% of users, like, I feel like that might be a little
bit of a tricky sell if you're trying to talk about it in a report, but if you can combine it with 8%
from Safari and the 25% on mobile, like there's a decent amount of users that potentially could get
affected by a, um, same site or let me see if I can say this properly, a cross site attack, right? Um,
uh, C surf attack, uh, without, you know, these, these same site lacks default protections in place.
So, uh, I don't know, it's just helpful to have the numbers and be aware of these sort of things,
you know, 15% on, on desktop, 24% on mobile, not insignificant numbers. Um, but I think this is also
a really good statistic for the people on the program side as well, because as much as I hate to put,
you know, so severity lowering weapons in your hands.
Yeah. That's exactly what I was going to say. You know, like the reality is that when programs come
back with these, you know, if anybody reports something that's like, oh, this only works on
edge or this only works on Firefox, then, you know, you, you can't really be surprised when they're
going to put a damper on the severity or they're going to lower your bounty or whatever, because
if you look at the raw numbers, if it's not affecting Chrome, like, well, we'll start there.
If it's not affecting Chrome, then it's already like missing almost, almost half of the market.
And then if it's not affecting, yeah. Yeah. Right. And then if it's not affecting, uh, you know,
Safari or edge, then that's the other like third. Yeah. I mean, you're, you're basically at, you know,
10% or less of the market. So it's a very, very difficult case to make, but you can still report
it nonetheless. I think programs will still fix it. It's just going to be way lower impact.
Yeah. Yeah. I think so too. All right, dude, I'm going to tell you a story from this week of,
uh, bug bounty hunting. Cause I was, um, let's see, how big do I want to make this? I want to
make this pretty big. I think I was signing up for a service that I will use, you know,
that I am using on a regular basis, um, that has a bug bounty program that I'm aware of.
Yeah. And then, um, let's say within the past year and a half, there has been a, a live hacking
event on this target and they're, they got a lot of reports and a lot of eyes. It was a pretty big
one, you know? Um, and I found a bug, uh, while I was signing up for this service that was just like
right in front of me, you know? Um, so one it, it, and I looked back at my logs and I looked at this
endpoint before, and I missed it. Uh, I missed this exploit and what it was is this is a part of the
OAuth flow and it was just a classic example of, um, being able to use the at sign to bypass, uh, host
restrictions, um, on the redirect URI. And it, they weren't allowing slash, uh, you know, in that
username password section on the, on the left side of the app, they weren't allowing, um, uh, backslash,
they weren't allowing hashtag, they weren't allowing a bunch of stuff, but they made the mistake of
allowing a question mark in there, which makes it a part of the query. Um, that, you know, and they were
still parsing it as if that part that was following the ad sign was the domain rather than the part
before. Um, so that allowed me to just completely hijack the account and, uh, it would, it had to be
sent to the root of my domain, which is a little tricky, but, uh, you know, and I had to go in
there and like edit my index.php page or whatever. Um, super interesting, but yeah, be, be making sure,
you know, being thorough with these sorts of things when you're testing these, you know,
trying the at sign, trying the, the, the question mark, the hashtag, the forward slash, the backslash,
all of the terminating characters really important because sometimes you get that one that just works.
So this was in a username and it would allow you to like do like, basically like to do like a forgot
password, but it would send it to the wrong place. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
totally different. Sorry. So it was an OAuth flow, right? With the redirect URI. So, you know,
where it sends the code to afterwards and it's using the username and password part, you know,
for basic auth of the URL. So you can do like, you know, you can do like HTTPS, uh, colon slash,
slash test at google.com and it'll still send it to google.com. But if you do test question mark at
google.com, then it'll send it to test. Right. And so that was how I sort of broke that off flow. And
they, they still said, okay, this host is whatever host it was, but actually my, my domain was before
the at sign terminated by a question mark there. And so the actual browser navigated to my domain
with the valuable code that can be used as the session token. Gotcha. That's super cool. That's a
cool bug, man. Yeah. You'll have to tell me who, uh, who was on after. I'll tell you afterwards. Yeah.
It's kind of annoying that I missed it before, but I was, I was like, ah, someone must have found this.
And they just must've like, do you think it was there the whole time? Oh yeah. It was there for
sure. I have validation that it was there. Um, but, uh, yeah, it just somebody, we, we all missed it.
And it's like, oh my gosh, I can't believe that happened. Um, so yeah, kind of a crazy, crazy one
from this week. Cool. Um, I saw that you, you made a tweet about, um, Kaido workflows.
Yeah. Do you finally. Okay. So check this out. Kaido is, um, dropping global workflows this week.
Uh, probably by the time this airs, but if not short, shortly after, um, what this means is that
you will be able to build workflows and then reuse them across different projects, which is something
that I feel like should have been there from the very beginning. Uh, but it is something that the
community has been asking for, for a little while. And it's really helpful because you can build out
these automations that make your work, your hacking workflows. Yeah. Workflow. I mean, that's why they're
called workflows much, um, much more efficient. And, uh, so I'm really looking forward to that release.
Plus they're easy to share now too. Um, thanks to even better, um, from Bebex. And I, I wanted to shout
out as well that I, in conjunction with the announcement that this is going to be in the next,
um, you know, release, uh, we saw a bunch of pull requests go into, uh, the Kaido slash workflows repo
on GitHub for a bunch of really awesome, um, things like generating a CSERF POC, like doing something that
should have been in birth since forever, which is, um, JSON to form form data and form data back to JSON,
uh, yeah, encoding for, for the request body. Um, and these are all done by, by Ryota. Um, cool.
And so definitely very high, high quality code and it's good to see another, another, you know,
top hacker investing into the Kaido environment. Yeah. This is really awesome. It's cool to see. Um,
it's cool to see that there's like a community sort of like, you know, way to contribute these and
share these with other people and create a really awesome space of different workflows.
Um, and like show what's possible, et cetera. Yeah. So yeah, this is really, really cool.
Previously you could export them and stuff like that and then reimport them into different projects,
but it was kind of a pain. So having these be global, I think will be, be really helpful.
Um, super awesome. Yeah. And we've been seeing a lot of more investment into the Kaido
environment lately, which is cool. Um, definitely excited about that and excited about building some
stuff out. I've got a, I've got a topic next week for the pod that I'm going to talk about some ideas
for a kind of plugin that I want to develop slash maybe someone in the community will develop, who knows,
um, uh, that I'm going to talk about. So we'll, we'll save that one for next week though.
Um, that's awesome. Dude. So I was going back through my, uh, bookmark tweets, uh, in prep for this episode,
and I saw this tweet from, uh, November, 2023. Uh, and it was when we were talking about like
doing like a lot of app redirects, uh, a lot of redirects to app schemes and this, this dude comments
on it and, and he says, uh, I technology here instead of malicious app installed, uh, a user could
directly steal the token if their server, uh, to their server, if the scheme controlled is allowed.
Uh, okay. So it's a little bit, a little bit, I haven't read it out loud yet, but, uh, essentially
what he's saying here is that if you can control any scheme, um, for an app, then you could just
trigger Google Chrome and then Google Chrome has this, uh, Google Chrome colon slash slash navigate
question mark URL equals that will navigate Google Chrome to that specific URL. Um, and
so I don't know, what do you think about this? Do you think this is something useful to use in a
chain from a mobile perspective or? Yeah. So like I said, um, I think Chrome is the default browser
on Android now. So it does kind of assume that Chrome is installed. Um, but it probably is,
I think in most cases, that's not to say, you know, people haven't downloaded Firefox or some other
opera or whatever on their phone, but I think probably in most cases, I'd really like to see the breakdown
actually by OS for, um, mobile for what the browsers, um, are. Cause I, I'd imagine like Android is
probably very, very high percent using Chrome. Oh yeah. That being said, um, there are definitely
some good cases to use this. So if you were to just open HDB or HTTPS by default, the system is
going to use your browser. It's going to prompt you to use any app that can open browser links. So it
does almost the same thing, but I think if there's some sort of check, for example, like say, um,
say the app is checking where, where a link, you know, any link that gets opened, what's the,
what's the scheme on it. Um, and if it's checking for HTTP and HTTPS and doing some extra logic there,
you could bypass that with Google Chrome. Um, you know, if you instead just link out directly to the
Google Chrome app and then have that open the URL for you, you don't have to worry about the app logic
trying to, you know, prevent you from going to a certain URL or parsing the host or something like
that. If it's looking at the HTTP schemes. Um, but yeah, I think this is a, this is a really creative
way of, you know, sort of in implicit, it's not really open reader. It's, it's like an implicit
open reader. It's a gadget. You know what I mean? It's a gadget. It's a gadget. It's a good gadget.
For mobile stuff for sure. Um, yeah, I hadn't really, of course, you know, you, you could just use the
HTTPS scheme that that makes sense too, if any scheme is being permitted. Um, but yeah, like you
said, if there's restrictions around those, then that, that could be interesting. I wish there was
some way in mobile for you to do something like what we just talked about for the other a lot thing
where it's like, you know, I could do whatever at Google Chrome colon slash slash navigate question
mark URL equals blah, blah, blah. You know, that would be really cool. If there was some way to like,
essentially trash some text. Uh, so there are some ways, um, one of the ways.
But not prefix text, right? Not prefix. Yeah. So basically it would have to start with the same
scheme. Like it would have to be like Google Chrome colon slash slash and then the parsing problem.
Yeah. Um, but there are some ways to do it. I believe Baggy Pro's golden URL tricks.
Um, we talk about this all the time. Yeah. We talk about this one all the time, but I'm
fairly certain there's some tricks in there that still work, um, for this type of, you know,
hosts like parsing problems with like backslashes and ads and stuff.
Hmm. Hmm. Yeah. That we'll, we'll have to, I have to double, double check that. I feel like
I can't read this, um, you know, write up by Baggy Pro enough times. Like every time I come back to this,
it's like the gift that keeps on giving or something like that. Um, but yeah, I think that could also be
another really interesting area of research is like, let's look into the Android scheme parsing.
Uh, I mean, we have the source code so we can just look at source code, um, and see how that works
specifically if there's any way for us to, you know, put some text in there, get it parsed as a
different part of the scheme or something like that, that would allow us to do something with a
starts with, because I feel like a lot of these redirects for mobile are like, okay, starts with Google
Chrome, you know, if that was what it was redirecting to, or starts with, you know, Snap or whatever.
Um, and then if it does, then they're like, all right, whatever. Um, so if you could find a way to
redirect to a different scheme, uh, like the Google Chrome scheme, then you could exfiltrate out pretty
much anything you want, um, via those OAuth flows, which would break a ton of websites.
Yeah. No kidding. Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. Um, I saw this really cool thing on Twitter while we're
talking about Twitter. I think a lot of this stuff today is from Twitter. But, um, you mentioned
that there was this guy who's been doing a really awesome self documentation, self blog type of thing.
Ah, yeah. Um, of your bug bounty method. This is the methodology that you tweeted a long time ago,
right? Yeah, sort of. So I won't take full credit for this. Um, as far as like, oh, you know, this guy,
and I'm, I'm sorry, dude, I'm going to butcher your name, but it's Shreyas Shreyas Shavon. Um,
and essentially what they did is they, they did one of these really cool detailed write-ups that we
talk about from time to time on the pod. Um, but essentially he's saying the, the roadmap I, I followed
to make 15 K in bounties in my first eight months, starting from zero. And if you look at the, the notion
site that he links out to very detailed, you know, he's got exactly how many hours he spent each month,
how many days he worked, how much bounty he's got, how many reports he submitted, number of programs,
et cetera. Um, and, uh, just very, very detailed stuff. And, you know, I won't say that this is like
the best pathway that someone could have taken. You know, in my opinion, if you read through his
actual roadmap, I think there's a lot of things in there, there's a couple of things in there that,
that, um, I wouldn't necessarily agree with, but one of the things that he does, uh, mention,
and he doesn't give me credit for this specifically. So I'm not trying to steal credit for this, just,
just to be clear. Um, although he does shout us out at the, in one of the tweets at the bottom of the,
uh, of the write up, um, is this whole concept of making sure you're doing enough hacking while
you're learning. So he, he, he talks about this concept of 60% hunting, 40% learning, 80%, you know,
hunting 20% learning, you know, making that shift as you're continuing to grow. And this is something
that I'm telling people in the CTVB discord all the time that are, that are new, that message me and
are like, Hey, what do I do? You hack, you get out there and you fail and you fail and you fail and you
look at that as a part of your training because it is. And eventually you can only bang your head
into a wall for so long. And, uh, before the wall breaks down. So, yeah, I mean, being failure versus
like good, but you also have to learn when it's productive, right? Like to, to fail. And so, you
know, getting that hands-on experience is really important. Um, what do you, what do you mean by that?
What do you mean by that? What do you mean by, by being failure averse is, is good?
Well, I think like there are lots of areas in life where being failure averse is even life or death,
right? Like it, for example, like driving a car, right? Like if you take the wrong turn or you turn
at the wrong time, like that could be potentially fatal. Um, but that's not like in bug bounty,
if you take the wrong turn, it's not fatal, right? Like that's a learning experience. Um,
and that's something that could be useful, but it can also be a really big time sink.
So training yourself to be able to identify those situations and spend time failing so that you can
better identify when something is not necessarily a failure or when you can trust your gut or not
trust your gut. Like we talked about last week. Um, you know, there's a lot of aspects of bug bounty
where failing can be good or can lead you to find other things that, you know, maybe gadgets or things
that are just like, you know, useful to know. Um, but it's important to push yourself to go into those
areas, even if it might not feel comfortable, even if you think that you are going to fail just because
there might be more there than you realize. Yeah. I thought I disagreed with you on that,
but I think I do agree. You know, there's, there's, there are areas where it's do or do, you know?
Um, but I think bug bounty is an area where, and I think most, most skills that you're trying to learn
rather than actions you're trying to perform, like driving a car or something like that, um,
should be failure should be looked at as almost a celebration of having done the thing in the first
place, you know? Um, and, and as a part of the process, if 100%, uh, and so I think that for people
like me who are essentially success obsessed, I am very driven by success and, uh, the, the feeling of
achievement. Um, I think it's really hard to reframe that, but if you can, then it will help you push
through those beginner stages, which I think is what deters almost everyone. Uh, because those
beginner stages can be really difficult when you're failing and failing and failing and failing.
Yeah, for sure. And I'm the same way, you know, I, I, I don't think anybody really likes to fail.
Yeah. Um, but you can learn to, you know, sort of fail elegantly or, you know, to take it not as a
failure, but as a learning process. Yeah, for sure. A couple, a couple more things I wanted to,
to shout out on, on this writeup one, I just appreciate the commitment to it. You know,
how much detail went into recording all this stuff and then putting it on a public, you know, page where
people can benefit from seeing your consistency and, um, to achieve your goals. And I also want to
highlight that, um, around nine months in, he started in July. He, um, uh, did this in, wrote this
up in March. Um, he's starting to actually see some good traction last month. He made 14 grand,
excuse me, uh, 14 grand from, from bug bounty. Um, and this is very, it's not consistent with that
writeup that I, that I did, um, on my, that's pinned to my Twitter profile. Um, in that he should
have been seeing sort of increasing amounts of bounties as he continues to go, um, over the past
couple months, but, um, he is seeing his first five figure month about nine months in, you know,
eight to nine months in, which I think is about accurate. I think you could get to the point where
you're making, uh, you know, five figures a month in bug bounty after really, really working your ass
off for, for nine months. Yeah. Which is a really good reality check too. I think a lot of people
don't really, they think like, okay, like I'm going to, you know, read some stuff for a month and then
I get bounties next month. Right. It's like, uh, not really. Yeah. Yeah. There's definitely going to be,
you know, small bounties and failures along the way. Um, but seeing these sort of write-ups are with
transparent details, really, really encouraging, especially when it's been such a long process for
this, I mean, this is 600 hours put into this thing. So, um, definitely applaud this person's
commitment and, uh, yeah, man, if I could long a person, you know, if I could invest into a person,
I would be willing to bet that this person's going to make a chunk in bug bounty in the future.
Nice. That's awesome. And, and that's, that's high praise from, from me.
Yeah, that's awesome. Yeah, man. I can see the writing on the wall for sure. Um, and another,
another piece of that was that he said, Hey, I'd write, you know, a step nine of his process.
I'd recommend reading at least a thousand of the hacker one reports. Yeah. I don't even know how
many hacker one reports are there. You know, I don't even know, but he, he said that he went through
and read a bunch of them. Um, and I think that takes a lot of commitment to go through and read
a lot of those. Um, I will say disclose hacker one reports are like free blog posts. Yeah. It's,
it's a really good resource for just understanding how other hackers think and what stuff leads to
vulnerabilities and like why it's impactful. And especially when there's like good, good
communication between the program and the researcher and stuff. Like it's really, it's nice to see those
kinds of examples that you can think about in your own communications and on your own reports.
Yeah. A hundred percent. And, and sort of in line with that, I kind of also want to recommend one
other blog, uh, monkey hacks. Um, this is by Kieran. Um, and he's every, I read these every single week
he's, or every single time he sends them out, uh, uh, sort of an update on his, uh, his a hundred
hour bounty challenge. He's at 13 and a half K. Um, and he's got 63 hours left. So he's only, you know,
37 hours in, so he's doing pretty well. Um, but this is another person that's kind of doing, uh,
an update on a pretty regular basis. We mentioned Alex Chapman doing an update on a pretty regular
basis of their bounty progress. So I really liked this trend. I think it's, I think it's encouraging for the
community. Yeah. Sweet. Yeah. I totally agree. Um, all right, let's see what else we got on the,
on the, um, on the list for today. Um, okay. So I'm gonna, I'm gonna jump to the last one real
quick and then we'll come back. Um, so once again, going through the bookmarks on, uh, on Twitter,
super valuable. Uh, and I noticed this, uh, yeah, it's helpful, man. You know, it's hard to go back
through and, and like look at those on a fairly regular basis. Uh, just cause you forget, but
when you, for me, you know, when I'm in an environment where I'm like, Oh, let me try to,
you know, deliver the most high quality book, any content I can. I, that's a place for me to get data.
Um, so it's nice. I really liked that about prepping for these podcasts that I get to go back and sort of
review that stuff. Um, yeah, for sure. And one of the nuggets that I found was a post from
Portsweger research, just, just probably about a month ago. Yeah. A month ago. Um, announcing
that they had a high quality contribution to the XSS, uh, cheat sheet by someone named Hans machine
or Hans machine. Um, and this is the use of the on form data, um, sort of event handler. And the,
the payload is, is form tag on form data equals alert one. And then inside the form tag, there's a button.
And if you click it, it triggers on form data. Um, not, not something really super
revolutionary, but cool nonetheless might definitely get you past some, some laughs.
Um, but more so July, I kind of wanted to talk about the process for this. Cause it's like,
how do new event handlers get added, you know, into, into chromium or like, why are we just figuring
out about this now? Um, so I went down this tangent of like, let me see how this happens. And here,
Joel, do you know where it happens? Just to, just to test your, I do now, but I didn't, I didn't before.
Okay. Well, one of the, yeah. Thank you for actually reading my document that, um,
um, uh, essentially what I discovered was one of the best places to see where this is happening
is the blink, uh, blink dev Google group. And which blink is the, like the code word for
Chrome, right? Is that my correct? You know, I think it is the code word for Chrome's
HTML, maybe not just HTML, just its renderer. Um, which is, I'm not really sure.
Yeah. Yeah. Here we go. Blink is the rendering engine used by Chromium.
Yeah. I think it's Chromium's rendering engine and they do this awesome thing in this Google group
where they will, uh, put like a post up and, you know, get comments from the community on, um,
on any feature that they intend to ship. So they'll prefix the subject of the message to the Google
group with intent to ship, blah, blah, blah, blah. And I'm just like, cool. Perfect. You know,
like, like that is exactly what I want to see. Um, so for the, for the critical thinkers in the, um,
in the CTPB discord, I went ahead and added a, uh, a channel, exclusive channel that will, um,
give us an alert anytime there's a new, uh, update to this, this feed. Uh, and so we can stay on top of
what things blink is intending to ship and stay on top of what features we may be able to exploit, uh,
in that, those new functionalities. Yeah. It's super awesome. I mean,
this is one of those really, um, unique things that we are trying to provide to the critical
thinkers as, you know, extra value for, um, subscribing and being part of that community.
And, um, you know, so if you want to be on the front edge of all those new features that are being
added into Google and the rendering engine and new event handlers and all that kind of stuff and get
the X success before anybody else does, um, you know, definitely go ahead over to the CTPB discord.
Um, discord.gg slash CTPB, right? Yeah. We've got that one or we've got CTPB.show slash discord.
That one works too. So either of those links, they should take you right to the server. And,
um, yeah, we have a new channel in there intent to ship and it's monitoring for those, uh, those changes,
which is super awesome. It wasn't, it wasn't like something super hard to implement. And obviously you
can just like subscribe to the, you know, Google group if you want, but they're going to like bomb you
with emails because it's a very active Google group. Um, so maybe you could set something up where it's
like some fancy filter or something like that. That's, I don't even know how you do that, but,
uh, I I've got it all coded up and pushed into the discord bot now. Um, so, uh,
quick, quick, quick win for any of you that are critical thinkers or past guest speakers that have
access to that channel. Um, I'm definitely, I'm definitely going to keep, keep an eye on it. Dude,
there's some really cool ones in here. Um, I didn't actually put this in the, in the doc. Sorry about
that, but I'll, I'll, I'll put it in discord right now here, go to that, go to that link. Um, one of
the ones that was kind of interesting was these regex modifiers that they're intending to ship that
they announced late March that they were intending to ship, um, where as a part of the regex modifiers
that they announced late March that they were intending to ship, um, where as a part of the
regex modifiers, um, that they're intending to ship that they announced, um, late March that they
were intending to ship, um, where as a part of the regex modifiers, um, that they're intending to ship,
um, where as a part of the regex, it looks like you can add, uh, a flag for various things like,
um, you know, the I, the M, the S flags inside the actual pattern, making something like, uh,
case insensitive and that sort of thing, which I feel like is pretty useful for regular expression
injection. You see that? Super interesting. Yeah. And what's, what's even more interesting is
it seems like there's people who are on this, on this like mailing list or whatever, or who are
like reviewing this stuff who work at other companies. Yeah. Yeah. There is. There's like
some Shopify people and that's what, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So I don't know that they've got this like,
looks good to me. One looks good to me. Two looks good to me. Three, you know? Yeah. I, I, I wonder what,
but I, cause the group is open to anyone. So I could just respond and be like, looks good to me.
Like some random dude, you know, like XC, XC round two. Yeah. Like looks great. Um, so yeah,
but definitely a cool place to, to look around and read through. I know there's some, some, um, CSS,
uh, stuff that's being pushed soon regarding transitions. Um, there's some, I don't even,
some of this stuff is like way, like, I like, like this one declarative shadow dom serialization.
Like what's a shadow dom? Like, that sounds like super, that's the secret dom that runs all the
other doms. Yeah. Well, either that or something else, but, um, uh, yeah, it's, there's, there's
definitely some, some deep browser knowledge that could be gained from reading through these and
kind of understanding how this whole process flows. So I thought it'd be a cool shout out.
This is always something that's fascinated me. Um, you know, how, how this stuff is like where it's
defined and how it's defined. And, and so, yeah, this is super cool. Um, I'm definitely gonna be
doing some deep dives into a bunch of these different issues and pull requests and stuff
and just figuring out how this stuff works. Yeah. Alrighty, man. Um, last, last topic that I had
today, uh, for today was, I was just gonna give you sort of like a rundown of the CD and CGI research
that I was talking about from before that I said that I would do, and I have somewhat done in a rare turn
of events. Okay. Wow. The turnaround. I mean, this is execution, you know, incredible.
So, all right, you know what, before we get into that, actually let's talk about that because,
um, I don't like that. I just said, uh, just flicked that, that cup over there. I don't like
that. I just said that in a rare turn of events, I have followed through on the research that I would
like to be doing. Um, but I feel like it's hard as a book bounty hunter and as a full-time book bounty
hunter to justify spending a bunch of time researching for zero days or something like
that on a specific target when you do not have an application for that. Do you, do you feel that?
I mean, yeah, I mean, and we talked about this cause one of the things that we wanted to look
at is kind of like this. Um, like one of the things we wanted to look at was a, a piece of software.
Yeah. That, I mean, there are everybody, a lot of people use it, so I'm sure we'll be able to find
instances of it. But that being said, it is a huge time investment and, um, energy investment
into something that may or may not pan out. It doesn't have like a immediate, um, impact at the
moment. And it's also like longer scale research, but I think it's still worth it. You know, I, I think,
um, depending on what it is and depending on how much time you spend on it, it can be really worth it.
And it can be one of those things that depending on how widely it's used,
just, you know, I think we talked about this, right? Like imagine you find an XSS zero day in Google
ads or Google tag, Google analytics, right? Like any of those things that are used on such a large
percentage of the internet, right? Like you can imagine the, the impacts of that would be
very, very broad and sweeping. So that's probably a place to spend, you know, where your time investment
is going to be worth it. But if it's some really abstract tool that it's only used by one company,
you should probably be looking at that one company's bounty table and deciding if a zero
day in this piece of software is going to pay off and be worth it.
Yeah. Yeah. And, and I mean like a zero day in, in cloud flare, I mean, once again,
it would have large reaching impact, but it is a one place fix as well. Like, and sort of the
motivation for, cause we talked about at the beginning of this year, you know, wanting to do
some more research this year. So I was kind of reviewing that goal and being like, all right,
you know, maybe I should lean a little bit more research heavy for the next couple months.
Yeah. And, um, yeah, like the things that have one location fix are probably not that great for us
as bug bounty hunters. Like if I pop something on CD and CGI, I'm going to feel super cool and it's going
to be super bad-ass. Uh, but then I'm going to, you know, even if I report it to like everyone,
then, then it's going to be like, oh, okay. You know, cloud flare needs to fix it. Cause you can't
even really put a laugh in front of a laugh, you know, like, um, and so then cloud flare is going
to fix it. It's going to fix it for everyone. And I probably would just get the one bounty from,
from cloud flare, you know, cause everyone else doesn't really have an actionable remediation step.
Um, and so I don't know, you know, maybe there's, there's cool research there and maybe there's,
maybe there's not, but, um, I'll talk about the methodology nonetheless. So I wanted to see, you know,
what are all the files that are available via this, uh, CDN CGI endpoint. And so I did, I did something
scary and I went to, to Google big query and I queried the HTTP archive dataset, man. And we use the
prepaid card. Okay. So does that not freak you out? Have you ever done that before? That you can click
a button and accidentally cost yourself like $500? Not even $500 dude. I read an article on this that
was like, I accidentally charged myself 14 grand and I'm like, Oh no, like this is terrifying.
Oh my God.
But, um, the response from like the Google smear or whatever was like, dude, I'm so sorry this
happened to you. You know, it was very emotionally mature response to, he was like, you know, I can't
imagine what it might must be like to, to, you know, see that number or whatever. But for you to do this,
you had to be pretty dumb. Essentially it was, and he's like, for example, this is the query that
would cost $14,000. And essentially he's like select star on star, you know, it's like, it's like,
like, why would you run that? And, and, uh, and so I don't know, it was a good cautionary tale for me,
but I was like sweating as I pressed the run button and like trying to figure out exactly like
how to optimize all this. But at the end of the day, I queried the whole HTTP archive for every,
um, CD and CGI, uh, URL that I could find. And I've been kind of piecing through them. There's some
really interesting looking JS files there, um, that are kind of small, so pretty able to be parsed and
stuff like that. Um, and I might drop the, that whole list of, of, um, files into the, the CTVB
discord one, um, once I'm done with the research, just if anybody else wants to do some follow-up research.
Um, cool. But one of the ones that was most interesting, uh, was this whole, um,
concept surrounding the, the email hiding feature of, of Cloudflare. And I went and I found a tweet by,
um, Masato Kinogawa, which I think we mentioned before on the pod, um, about a, a XSS auditor bypass.
So you remember when Chrome had like, yeah, XSS auditor, um, they were able to use this sort of
chain to bypass XSS auditor and run arbitrary, you know, uh, JS code, but, but it still works. So if,
if you look at this, if you will link the tweet in the description, um, in Masato's website is down,
um, but, um, the, the, the payload is this SVG, and then he does a script tag and then he does, uh,
SVG and then the data dash CFE email, and then a hex encoded string, um, attribute. Okay. And then
a bunch of other stuff. And then what ends up happening is the code for the email or hiding thing
we'll go through and decode hex decode, whatever is in that data CFE email, um, attribute.
It's just a CF email. Oh yeah. CF email. I mean, that makes sense. Cloudflare email.
Um, it'll decode whatever's in there and then just replace that whole tag with it. Uh, and,
and I was like, and it uses inner HTML and everything, man. And I was like, I was poking at it for so long,
trying to be like, there's gotta be like some way for me to escape this, but not that I can find. Um,
okay. And, and so I don't think there's any like XSS or anything there, but it is a very cool way
for you to use Cloudflare to obfuscate your payloads. And also, um, sort of like we learned from the,
the, um, Masato Kinugawa team's research, sometimes, um, various HTML parsers and stuff like
that will allow you to specify, I think actually Dom purifies default, uh, allows you to specify data dash
attributes. Um, and, and so that could allow you to smuggle some payloads through because there's
some post-processing that's being done with it, uh, via this Cloudflare, uh, script.
Man, there's, there's a lot of really interesting things with like those data attributes. Um,
there's some other frameworks that use that type of stuff like, um, Angular. Yeah. Is it Angular?
NG, like NG data and NG. Yeah. All that kind of stuff, like super, super weird, funky behavior.
And I bet there's probably more of this stuff. You said that you've done some research. So I imagine
that there's, uh, there, there is some additional stuff. I just mostly that one that just kind of blew
my mind, uh, from that team's research that I mentioned a second ago of, of NG init being able to
be specified as a class attribute. So inside the HTML tag class equals NG dash init colon
JavaScript. And that will just get run. It was like, what? Um, you know, what's funny, dude, is I,
I, I like somebody had some relevant, um, you know, quip about that on Twitter. And I was like,
I posted a picture of that screenshot and it ratioed hard, you know, and it was like blowing up like,
Oh wow, this is, this is really interesting. I'm like, yeah, we talked about it on the pod and
Masato released it months ago, you know? So I don't know, man, it's good, but it's good to get the
distribution on that. Yeah. It's super, super cool. Well, this is awesome. Yeah. I'm looking forward
to, uh, to seeing that list. Um, yeah, yeah. Yeah. So I'm gonna, I'm gonna continue doing a little
bit of research on it. Um, the, the JS files are really interesting. Unfortunately, there hasn't been
much that's panned out. It's actually a little bit less scope than I thought it was. It's just a lot
of the same files. So I'm condensing it down a little bit, trying to find the outliers. Um,
but I would say probably optimistically, I'm looking at like a CSP bypass rather than a,
an, you know, a global cloud flare XSS, just kind of looking at the writing on the wall there. So
yeah, we'll see how that goes. Yeah, absolutely. Um, all right, man. I think that's it. Is that a wrap?
I think that's a wrap. All right. Sweet. Peace. That's fun. See ya.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking. Thanks so much for listening. And if you
want more critical thinking content, head over to ctbb.show slash discord, join the discord.
There's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there. And if you want to support
the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you access to masterclasses, AMAs,
hackalongs, exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel with us. We'll see you there.